une aide-soignante toute seule pour
s'occuper de quinze patients qui sont
alignés les uns à côté des autres en
attente sourde
c'est tout est mélangé une jeune à côté
de 20 ans à côté d'un papy alzheimer qui
est sans arrêt en train de se découvrir
enfin voilà c'est pas possible il
continue le combat pour améliorer leurs
conditions de travail et préserver une
qualité de soin descente
voilà deux mois que les urgentistes du
centre hospitalier de mâcon sont en
grève et les raisons ne manquent pas ya
quelques semaines ennuis une collègue
s'est retrouvé à gérer deux services
avaient tout seul c'est à dire 40
patients voilà donc je pense que pour
les familles qui ne l'ont pas su parce
que évidemment ça c'est des choses que
l'on tait mais en termes d'insécurité
pour les patients c'est quand même
quelque chose de dating et ses soignants
sont à bout de souffle
en tout 10 arrêts maladie ont été
comptabilisés en juin soit un quart des
effectifs ces grévistes exigent le
recrutement de six personnels soignants
pour les services de jour comme de nuit
la direction qui n'a pas répondu à nos
sollicitations propose pour le moment
seulement trois renforts l'hôpital peine
à recruter manque de candidats manque
d'attrait aussi les cdd s'enchaînent on
titularise plus là la valorisation
salariale est pas du tout là les nuits
sont pas du tout valoriser un gagneur on
gagne une misère à travailler de nuit à
rien de motivant dans tout ça donc la
vocation ça ça va bien cinq minutes je
vais encore mais tous ces souffles et
c'est urgentistes compte poursuivre le
mouvement jusqu'à la fin de l'été